this is Larry he's a squirrel he likes
nuts in 2019 he went into an electric
box in Kettering Ohio is this a nut it
was not a nut he broke the electric box
and caused a blackout for 20,000 people
Larry isn't alone squirrels do this all
the time here's a map of their exploits
just last year but here's the thing
blackouts happen all the time for all
kinds of reasons like wildfires or
storms and in the last half century
there have been more and more power
outages because of weather and it will
only get worse because of our changing
climate the way we power the world is
fragile but there's a way to make it
more resilient our current energy system
looks like this right on top our power
plants which get their energy from a
variety of sources like fossil fuels
wind in the Sun they distribute
electricity down to thousands if not
millions of customers so it's a big
centralized system when you're sending a
lot of power over just a few lines that
means that a tree falling on those power
lines or a storm can easily knock out
power to a lot of people that's
AmeriCorps fun he writes about energy
policy for voxcom is not just an
inconvenience it can affect the lives of
thousands of people we saw after
Hurricane Maria in Puerto Rico a
blackout that lasted for months and
thousands of people died there are ways
to avoid this though some homes have
generators some neighborhoods have their
own solar panels in some places even
have their own small power plants like
the New York University campus during
Hurricane sandy in 2012 they were able
to keep the campus lit even when most of
downtown Manhattan went dark these are
all examples of a micro grid a
decentralized system that can sustain
itself when it needs to and the US
government has invested in this
technology
the military is very interested in micro
grids this is something that they've
invested in heavily to power
installations both in the United States
and also in foreign areas where they may
not have a reliable central power grid
that they can count on another area is
basically for remote isolated
communities that have a very fragile
intending us link to the Maine
power grid micro grids are very useful
during emergencies especially blackouts
but in an ideal world we don't just use
them for emergencies they could
restructure our current power system
well if your goal is to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions you want to try
to minimize the amount of fossil fuel
you use and maximize the amount of free
solar and wind energy you have those can
vary throughout the day and so you want
to route power from where it's sunniest
and windiest to the places that need it
most and that's where micro grids come
in micro grids can generate power using
green sources like wind and solar and
unlike the power plants they can store
that energy when it's no longer sunny or
windy micro grids can jump in and say
hey we have some power stored here and
they can share their stored energy back
up into the big grid but one big issue
is that a lot of utilities are
effectively monopolies and they're
regulated by regulators that are trying
to protect these old business models the
reason micro grids present a threat to
these companies isn't just that they
help you survive a blackout is that they
can also change the source of our power
and the direction it flows in
[Music]